نايم في التصنيف الامريكي باتت مجموعه
فاجنر الروسيه في نفس مستوى المافيا
الايطاليه وشبكات الجريمه المنظمه في
اليابان وروسيا اعلان وفا بنك منظمه
اجراميه دوليه سيتيح فرض المزيد من
العقوبات الامريكيه عليها وعلى من يدعمها
هكذا يحذر مجلس الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض
روسيا
ميليشيا المرتزقه فاجنر يعتقدوا انها
تاسست في عام 2014 لدعم غزو الجيش الروسي
شرق اوكرانيا يتشكل معظمها من معتقلين
ومساجين سابقين منحو فرصه الافراج مقابل
قتالهم لصالحها مذاك عملت في اوكرانيا
وليبيا وسوريا فضلا عن افريقيا الوسطى حيث
اتهمتها الامم المتحده بارتكاب انتهاكات
قد ترقى الى جرائم ضد الانسانيه
عن تنافس داخلي بينها وبين الجيش الروسي
على السلطه والنفوذ